véronique le maire tremblay s'est fait
discret aujourd'hui il va réagir
seulement demain mais vous qui
connaissez très bien le personnage à
quoi est ce qu'on peut s'attendre comme
réaction mais monsieur tremblay est
aujourd'hui que le procès de la prière
c'était le combat de service il vous
savez monsieur tremblay est un fervent
catholique qui va à l'église tous les
jours donc on peut présumer que c'est
une douche froide pour lui et ce serait
la deuxième douche froide en moins d'un
mois parce que pour la première fois
depuis que monsieur tremblay était lui
un sondage qui révèle que sa popularité
commence à diminuer justement en raison
de son attitude à l'hôtel de ville
quoi qu'il en soit monsieur tremblay a
toujours dit qu'il respecterait à la
lettre le jugement de la cour suprême
reste à voir sa réaction
demain mais ce sera aussi l'occasion de
faire le point sur les coûts de cette
défaite judiciaire en centaines de
milliers de dollars
après neuf ans ouais certainement alors
on se reparle tout ça demain merci
beaucoup véronique faut qu'ils aient et
je me tourne maintenant vers québec
sébastien on voit tout cette décision
relance le débat politique sur la
neutralité religieuse de l'état où on
est justement ce projet de loi que
promet le gouvernement
alors il l'est toujours attendre le
gouvernement qu'il pourrait présenter un
projet de loi sur la neutralité
religieuse de l'état d'ici le mois de
juin d'ici l'ajournement de l'été et
probablement que cette décision de la
cour suprême va étoffer sa position je
vous rappelle la proche du gouvernement
en attendant c'est une approche de
neutralité religieuse de l'état et pas
de laïcité
on est dans la nuance mais ils sont
importantes la laïcité pour le
gouvernement exclut toute religion alors
que la neutralité religieuse de l'état
fait plutôt référence au fait que ya pas
de religion privilégiée ou exclue bref
que l'état est neutre religieusement en
ne faisant pas de discrimination à
l'égard de quelque religion que ce soit
ça s'illustre par exemple le fait qu'on
permet aux employés de porter des signes
religieux tout en affirmant que l'état
est neutre religieusement donc en ne
faisant pas la promotion de quelques
religions que ce soit en tant
qu'institution et le fameux crucifix pas
de décision de ce côté là lance une
patate chaude mais vous savez les
parlementaires se sont prononcés
plusieurs fois pour maintenir le
crucifié à l'assemblée nationale parce
qu'on considère comme symbole du
patrimoine de l'histoire du québec
sauf qu'à partir du moment où la cour
suprême dit que l'état ne peut pas faire
la promotion de religion la question va
se poser est ce que la présence du
crucifix dans l'est
sur démocratique par excellence désir
l'assemblée nationale ce que cette
présence ne fait pas la promotion d'une
religion
la cour suprême ne tranche pas mais
disons que le débat politique et
peut-être lancer sur cette question oui
peut-être un peu plus calmement que la
dernière fois on l'espère merci beaucoup
sébastien et ce jugement rendu par la
cour suprême ne se limitera pas
uniquement à la ville de saguenay
elle va forcer plusieurs municipalités
du pays à revoir une pratique souvent
mises en place depuis des décennies
raphaël bouvier au clair le premier
musulman avoir été élu maire d'une
grande ville au canada il ne cache pas
sa foi mais qui verra s'il apportera des
changements la prière
multiconfessionnelle qui ouvre les
séances du conseil municipal de calgary
s'il répète que c'est un moment qu'il
aime beaucoup ailleurs au pays plusieurs
conseils municipaux ont déjà annoncé
qu'ils allaient cesser de réciter la
prière c'est le cas dans plusieurs
grandes villes comme ottawa à regina et
lévis la décision de la cour suprême
elle est logique qu'elle est sensée et
nous nous nous y adhérons certains comme
le maire de dieppe au nouveau brunswick
ont déjà envisagé un compromis il
demandera son conseil d'approuver le
retrait du mot dieu de la prière d'après
moi comme président de l'assemblée
d'avoir un moment où on met tout le
monde à l'ordre
et en même temps ou si ces quelques mots
définit un peu notre mission comme
conseil municipal
certaines questions se posent également
dans des législatures provinciales comme
au manitoba où la prière est récitée
depuis près de 80 ans
mais l'importance de la neutralité de
l'état cité par les juges de la cour
suprême donne en tout cas de l'espoir à
certains militants qui réclament un
moment de silence plutôt qu'une prière
qu'en début des sessions législatives
c'est le cas de cet athée qui aimerait
que les nombreuses croyances soient
mieux représentés à l'assemblée
législative de l'alberta
une assemblée où aucune cession ne
s'ouvrent sans que les mots dieu et
amène ne soit prononcé ici rappelle
bouvier oakley radio canada